now do you have your dog with you on
tour all the time Madeline Kahn
Chenoweth is has a bad heart now and she
can't fly and I wish so bad that I could
travel with her I miss her when I'm not
there but I do have a girl name called
Madol Natalie that stays alert called
your dog sitter
do you ever accidentally call her my two
dogs later in pom-pom Larry is what I
call special needs don't say that I can
hear you I know yes okay he's not the
sharpest post on the box but he's also
heated and his legs are getting weaker
and so I just call him wheels cuz I
think it's only a matter of time before
I just chopped up his legs and put those
wheels on you know the wheels on the bus
go running around but the bad thing is
my house has a lot of stairs so I can
even go up up and down exactly so I
think he'll have wheels for like a day
and then he'll just roll to his death
I do have an elevator I and you know
what I've actually thought about you
that's very Hollywood it'd be I may use
my elevator for my dog with wheels